live local now hard to believe summer
break is almost over
ccsc students go back to class august
9th the day is coming up pretty quickly
joining us here to talk about the the
upcoming school year live
dr teschara superintendent of ccsd good
to see you again in person for a change
absolutely it's great to be here good to
see you we're just talking about the the
flight we just
all witnessed together it's pretty cool
stuff let's talk about other
cool stuff the preparation to get kids
and teachers back in class obviously we
know things are changing because of the
pandemic
so where things stand right now what
should students what should parents and
staff
expect on august 9th well we're planning
to be face-to-face
five days a week in school for all k-12
students so we're excited that we're
welcoming our kids back to school our
teachers you know obviously
as things continue to change our goal is
to make sure
which has been our goal ever since we
closed down our schools opened up
schools
safely for our students and our adults
i know there's hybrid learning available
for students as well i think most kids
are going to go back into class
any clarity on potential whether
students will have to wear masks
anything along those lines vaccinations
well we've been waiting and working with
the county officials the southern nevada
health district since the pandemic
when we closed our schools has been a
constant discussion that we've had
we're waiting to see what the county
will do today in their in their county
commission meeting but you know
obviously
the priority is for us is the healthy
you know opening of schools our students
to be safe and our adults to be safe as
well so
we're you know waiting and seeing and
you know there's things that people are
saying well you know making the decision
you know things change last week you
know we're at a different point we're
seeing the the
uptake of our of our coveted numbers so
we you know got to look and see what we
are and then make a decision shortly and
august 9th as we mentioned it's about
three weeks or so away so
things could change obviously until then
but that's where things stand right now
you mentioned last year this time last
year there was a bit of a divide that
had developed between ccsd and the state
and governor sysolak with regards to
distance learning everyone was kind of
scrambling to try and make things
happen at the school education level
what confidence do you have from the
state
uh that they are behind what ccsd plans
to do
when it comes not only to federal
funding we'll get to that but also just
when it comes to getting kids in class
safely
well we've been working with the state
um you know since we closed we
you know opened schools in march the
state department the governor
the governor's office uh you know the
department of education worked closely
to open up in march they saw the
priority we had you know
our kids were struggling at home our
adults were struggling everybody was so
we focused
came together march 1 open schools and
in our pre-k
open you know for our secondary schools
and hybrid models so they're very
supportive we submitted our plan to the
state july 8th
that the board just approved and now
they're in line to where we are
and things have improved absolutely our
relationship has gotten a lot better and
you know believing where we're we're all
headed together so let's talk about uh
what
uh ccsd is working on right now the
outreach initiative there's
millions of dollars in federal funding
that ccsd can use right now
let's talk about where the money comes
from and where parents can essentially
help determine where it would go to
absolutely we have a great opportunity
in this community well across the
country this is the largest investment
of the federal government in public
education so very excited
about the opportunity and when we
started looking at where we were
you know looking at a kid's first agenda
the future of our kids what does this
community want for our kids not what dr
jarrah wants for our kids obviously
there's 310
000 families we serve so it's an
opportunity
for this community to to really look and
say what do we want the future of our
schools to be what do we want our kids
to learn where do we want to prioritize
our funding so
we have an outreach led by community not
by ccsd
you know i partnered with a public ed
foundation opportunity 180 the gwen
center
to really look at having community input
it's all up on on future
ccsd website for our community to
provide input for us
so just again clarity on on what the
initiative is called and how parents can
take part if they're watching at home
right now and they say hey we really
need some more money into this this and
this how can they take part
well they can participate in the
community input meetings future few
they can go to future ccsd.net and our
website you can see where all the
different meetings
i have 80 non-profit organizations that
are out there
doing the outreach so really provide
input on where we are where do we want
to prioritize our dollars where do you
think the most need is right now well
right now from what we saw obviously
i've been very vocal about the mental
health
of our students and our staff you know
technology we're going to continue
moving forward and the investment that
we've already made our digital learning
and that it's not
giving just the key to computers how are
we teaching and learning so we have
those two are our priorities and
obviously
accelerating the learning our students
we don't know
how you know fall how far we fell
academically and for us bringing our
kids
back in front of our teachers where they
belong is accelerating learning that's a
number three priority for us a lot to
work on dr jar it's good to see you in
person once again thank you for joining
us this morning we appreciate it thank
you and again you can find that
information on eightnewsnow.com